people are talking about your voice and
these sorts of things and it really made
me self-conscious for a second because I
thought am I being phony is this not my
voice and I'm thinking about cutting it
up with Hound though he lost the clothes
and the hairstyle but Austin Butler
can't seem to shake Elvis Presley's
signature southern accent at this point
I keep asking people is this my voice
the actor gets into it on The Graham
Norton Show and reveals one sand for all
I am getting rid of the accent there's
been a lot of talk about the blue Elvis
yeah I don't even think about it I I had
three years where that was my only focus
in life and three three years of
crooning like the king of
my vocal cords with all that singing
with one song requiring 40 takes
[Music]
it's one of those things that certain
things trigger it I think you can't help
but it becomes a fiber of your being you
know but I think there's a lot less of
it now I'm glad you say that I hear it
all the time yeah people had questions
when the SoCal native seemingly clung
onto Presley's Tennessee Cadence well
after the film wrapped there's people
out there who say that ever since I
played Elvis my voice has changed that
uh that it got deeper more Elvis
internet Jokes Aside you could say
Austin's the king of awards season
I'm ready
ready to fly I'm still getting used to
these types of things the actor was
honored at the Palm Springs
International Film Festival he won the
Golden Globe and now he's basking in his
first Academy Award nomination Austin
Butler and Elvis
you'll always be my bestest girl another
honor lots of love and admiration from
the Presley family it was mind-blowing
truly mind-blowing Elvis's daughter Lisa
Marie with E.T praising Austin's
performance as her dad two days before
she died suddenly at the age of 54. so
what was it like watching Austin during
this movie I really didn't know what
what to do with myself after after I saw
it because it was so incredible
following his Oscar nod Austin told The
Hollywood Reporter quote I just wish
Lisa Marie was here to celebrate today
with us still Austin says he's grateful
for their time together three years
spent exploring the life of her father
it's so important the movie is important
it's not just because it's my father
[Music]
Elvis is so loved and so iconic you feel
you feel responsibility playing any
human that has actually lived but with
him it's a weight like I never felt
before and there's a responsibility to
his family
[Music]